(whooshes and squeaks)
(pulsing music)
- What's up y'all it's
Delisa, about a month ago,
I saw this crazy video from this amazing
Brazilian hair stylist,
who is bringing back
my favorite trend, the frosted tip.
I asked around the
office if anybody wanted
to give it a go and I had some takers.
We're gonna go see them
get their tips frosted.
My hair says about me that
I watch a lot of anime
in the 90's and 2000's.
- I've been wanting to
do something to my hair
since JT did it back in the 90's.
- Pink might be too much,
maybe silver or I don't know
maybe platinum but I've just
like, so as you can tell
I'm really nervous.
- My name is Andreas Anastasis and this is
the Andreas Anastasis studio.
- I would hope that we're over any stigma
about men doing anything cosmetic.
We're gonna prove everybody
wrong by showing them
how it's done.
- Frosted tips, could be a
decade since I've done them.
- I've been wanting to pull someone's hair
through a cap for quite a
while now, so this is gonna be
really exhilarating for me.
(dance music)
Alright let's get started.
- I'm gonna get this as spiky as possible
because I'm gonna do a
process called shoe shining.
- [Matt] In middle school
we would have loved this.
The funny thing is this
isn't even the most product
I've ever had in my hair.
- [Andreas] You get really
good Wi-fi with this.
All your HBO channels.
- It feels a little bit like
I'm in a makeover portion
of how to be a K-pop star.
- [Jeff] Its the big reveal,
this is the most fun right here.
- Oh my god.
I don't have any words.
- Okay I can look now.
(gasps)
Yes.
- [Jeff] A throwback style
to it but we'll make it
our own version of it.
- [Matt] I kind of want to shave
so that the emphasis is on the hair
on my head and not on my mouth.
- It's my 90's dream even better
than I thought it could be.
- I'm so stoked, I can't wait
to see what everybody says.
I can't wait to see what my mother says.
- If they'll take me, I'm goin on tour
with the Backstreet Boys.
- I think Zane and I might actually have
a little bit of a competition.
(groovy music)
(gasps)
Do you like my hair?
- Oh my god, it looks so good.
(laughs)
- What did you do?
- The whole time we were
prepping for this video
we're talking about either
the JT or the Guy Fieri
and then they take that cap off
and I am 100% Guy Fieri.
- It's been an interesting kind of process
with how I dress myself in the morning.
I'm not sure what possessed
me to do all denim today.
Maybe it's the hair.
- That's looks great.
It's like the 90's.
- It's fun, it's cool to see
people's reactions to it.
I like it.
- It's like all of your middle
school dreams came true.
Can I touch it?
- [Matt] Dean would you
ever do frosted tips?
We think as a society that
anything that's about appearance
is inherently feminine,
I think it's something
that should all really strip down,
like what we've done to my hair.
I'm glad we didn't really
go all the way there,
we made it look like I still
belong in 2017, thankfully.
- I am at the forefront of the trend,
I'm gonna be the prophet
for frosted tips in 2017.
(electronic music)
(whooshes and squeaks)